Cómo cambia esta candidatura el panorama
del partido republicano de Cara a las
presidenciales
Buenas noches Bueno Este era una anuncio
esperado desde hace semanas e incluso
algunos meses y finalmente ese momento
ha llegado lo que es nuevo en toda esta
especulación del anuncio es que nadie se
esperaba por parte del gobernador que
este anuncio se haga en Twitter spaces
especialmente
Aparentemente va a ser una entrevista
conversación
entre el gobernador
y yo creo que eso le genera obviamente
atención no solamente de los
republicanos votantes que van a verle a
él como candidato ahora a la presidencia
sobre todo la nominación del partido
republicano pero también atrae la
atención francamente de la inmensa
mayoría del público que quiere ver esta
conversación entre el gobernador donde
seventy y el dueño de Twitter que
también tiene sus seguidores y en muchos
de sus tweets genera
conversación y genera controversia en
muchas ocasiones Así que vamos a ver
cómo sale ese anuncio para el gobernador
el día de mañana Bueno las leyes y
posiciones firmes de Run the santis
considerablemente radicales y han
permitido ganar apoyos de algunos
sectores
a ver algo que hay que aclarar aquí es
que los candidatos que están corriendo
dentro del partido en este momento
republicano no están haciendo campaña
pensando en la elección general de
noviembre del próximo año 2024 están
haciendo campaña pensando en ganar la
nominación del partido republicano en
ese aspecto Pues los políticos van
tomando diferentes Caminos Diferentes
acercamientos en términos de política
pública y propuestas
se ha hablado incluso bueno el tema de
el gobernador con
la disputa con Disney el tema migratorio
muchos otros temas que en algunos
sectores quizá ha incomodado pero en el
estado de la Florida la popularidad del
gobernador sigue Más allá del 50% el año
el año pasado ganó con 20 puntos de
ventaja la reelección y en el condado de
Miami y un condado demócrata por más de
20 años
lo ganó por muchos puntos que quiere
decir que independientes y demócratas
algunos demócratas y republicanos
votaron por él en esa elección y es una
elección reciente Así que yo creo que en
ese aspecto No creo que las políticas
públicas que han pasado en los últimos
semanas le vayan a afectar yo creo que
más bien tiene que hacer su estrategia
claramente para ganar votos electorales
en otros estados fuera de la Florida